willkommen an der militärakademie wiener
neustadt ich bin oberst markus reiser
der leiter der forschungs und
entwicklungsabteilung und heute wollen
wir uns in einem neuen video damit
befassen wie man versucht durch
propaganda unsere meinung zu einem
konflikt in diesem fall zum konflikt in
der ukraine zu beeinflussen
betrachten wir dazu zuerst die domäne
der modernen kriegsführung
traditionellerweise haben wir das domäne
der hand kriegsführung der maritimen
kriegsführung aber auch der luft
kriegsführung in den letzten jahrzehnten
an bedeutung gewonnen hat der weltraum
durch die satellitenkommunikation aber
auch durch die möglichkeit der gezielten
navigation von zb raketensystemen zwei
weitere domäne haben eine immer größere
bedeutung gewonnen einerseits der
cyberraum der sogenannte cyber domain
dass alle andere domäne durchdringt
nahezu zeitverzugs los und der
informationsraum der informationsraum an
dem wir permanent teilnehmer
wenn wir uns nur die kriegsführung
ansehen zu erkennen wir dass die
traditionelle form der kriegsführung die
mechanisierte kriegsführung immer mehr
in richtung weise einer digitalisierung
voranschreitet wir haben also hier den
umstand quasi einer sehr hohen
kommunikation untereinander in einer
struktur die es möglich macht ohne
zeitverzug zu wirken
tatsächlich ist dies aber nur ein
zwischenschritt zu einer weiteren form
der kriegsführung die von vielen bereits
als die zukunft beschrieben wird nämlich
der krieg um unsere haltung und um
unsere köpfe und das kostbarste gut ist
dabei die information und deren
interpretation
wir sehen heute begriffe wie hippie
kriegsführung
kognitive kriegsführung also gegen
unsere köpfe unserer haltung gerichtete
kriegsführung informations kriegsführung
und cyber kriegsführung das wertvolle
gut der information kommt vor allem zum
tragen in der informations kriegsführung
der schnittpunkt zwischen kognitiver
kriegsführung informations kriegsführung
aber auch dem cyber domain befindet sich
hier hier finden die so genannten
beeinflussen den operationen statt
wenn wir uns nun die ukraine ansehen so
ist interessant dass im cyberraum vor
beginn des konflikts beziehungsweise
auch während des staates zu massiven
cyber angriffen gekommen ist von der
russischen seite auf die ukrainische
seite das war aber nur ein teil dessen
was passiert ist auf der anderen seite
haben wir aber auch gesehen dass zum
beispiel die russische seite versucht
hat ganz gezielt durch informations
kriegsführung beeinflussung
durchzuführen ein gutes beispiel dafür
ist der unmittelbare auftakt der
offensive nur angriffe der russen auf
die ukraine so war es in den ersten
stunden der fall dass die russische
seite durch den einsatz von drohnen
gezielt kurznachrichten an jüdischen
soldaten vor allem im osten des landes
aus geschickt hat um damit zu
suggerieren dass die ukrainische
regierung das politische und
militärische zentrum bereits gefallen
ist es hat dafür die ukrainische seite
eine zeit gedauert um sicherzustellen
dass erkannt worden ist dass diese
information nicht stimmte
interessant war auch zu erkennen dass
die russische seite durchaus in der lage
ist über mehrere dimensionen den krieg
zu führen also in einer kombination
zwischen cyber angriffen und faktischen
durchführung von angriffen auf dem
gefechtsfeld wie zum beispiel man hier
erkennen kann wo einerseits cyber
angriffe im zusammenhang mit später
durchgeführten raketenangriffen zu sehen
sind
wenn man sich nun die frage stellt wer
steckt hinter diesen beeinflussen
operationen so ist es auf der einen
seite die russischen nachrichtendienste
wie der usa und fsb aber natürlich auch
das russische verteidigungsministerium
und das außenministerium durch eine
vielzahl von formaten versuchen sie
meinung zu beeinflussen dass nicht alle
bilder in diesem krieg stimmen das
möchten wir an einem einfachen beispiel
zeigen in dem folgenden video erkennen
sie scheinbar getötete ukrainische
soldaten die wenn sie das video fertig
betrachten plötzlich aufstehen und eben
nicht getötet worden sind ein klarer
fall der versuchten einflussnahme
dienst sid
durch stil
tatsächlich wirkt das kriegsglück hin
und her wir haben im prinzip einen
abnutzungskrieg das besondere an
abnutzungskrieg ist das ein
abnutzungskrieg sehr oft nicht an der
front entschieden wird sondern im
hinterland
was meine ich damit die russische seite
versucht ganz gezielt unsere ängste zu
schüren einerseits zu gerät sie uns dass
aufgrund des nicht vorhandenen getreides
möglicherweise hungersnöte und migration
vor der türe stehen durch die situation
in sapporo china oder die immer
wiederholte drohungen durch taktische
nuklearwaffen einzusetzen wird die angst
einer nuklearen katastrophe geführt über
allem schwebt aber die angst vor einem
möglicherweise harten winter und der
situation dass im westen ein
ökonomischer kollaps bevorsteht
die russische seite versucht das ganz
gezielt
anzusteuern einerseits indem sie
rohstoffzufuhr nach europa drosselt die
herausforderung besteht hier aus diesen
40 prozent der rohstoffe die aus
russland kamen aber andererseits auch
indem sie suggeriert was hier
möglicherweise passieren kann das zeigen
wir ihnen anhand dieses videos das kurz
nach der abschaltung von astrium 1 von
der russischen seite ganz gezielt
veröffentlicht worden ist um den
eindruck zu erwecken dass nun der kalte
winter bevorsteht
[Musik]
tipp
sie habe si
und da
yeah
[Musik]
die herausforderung besteht dass die
europäischen gesellschaften
scheinbar nicht zu resident sind wie
andere gesellschaften zum beispiel in
russland man erkennt es hier kurz an
dieser umfrage aus dem jahr 2015 also
bereits nach der ukraine krise von 2014
hier wurde die frage gestellt während
sie bereits für ihr land zu kämpfen sie
sehen dass europäische staaten wie zum
beispiel auch österreich und deutschland
einen sehr geringen anteil haben während
andere staaten wie die vereinigten
staaten von amerika oder in diesem fall
russland und china einen sehr hohen
anteil an bereitschaft haben auch
ukraine sticht heraus sicherlich auch
eine ursache der ereignisse von 2014
das bedeutet dass diese möglicherweise
nicht groß vorhandene resilienz gepaart
mit dem was an informations operationen
passiert möglicherweise dazu führt dass
der wille weiterzukämpfen gering ist auf
der anderen seite sehen wir aber dass
ereignisse wie zb der moskwa eigentlich
den russischen kampfeswillen sogar noch
steigern im sinne von jetzt geht es um
alles
nachrichten wie zum beispiel diese aus
dem mai oder auch die situation im juni
im ton bass oder gar die situation dass
wir nicht genug waffen liefern können
wie in diesem artikel vom juni
beziehungsweise die trennung dass die
sanktionen möglicherweise den besten
härter treffen als russland dienen genau
dazu diese information situationen
durchzuführen
die frage ist also was bedeutet erfolg
auf der einen seite sehen wir
spektakuläre erfolge auch der
ukrainischen seite wie zum beispiel
dieser angriff mit raketen auf dem
flugplatz von sagte der sehr erfolgreich
durchgeführt worden ist
oder auch die situation der beiden
offensiven einerseits die offensive in
person die von der ukrainischen seite
begonnen worden ist oder die situation
in haiti wo es einen durchschlagenden
erfolg der ukrainischen seite gegeben
die russische seite gekommen ist die
frage ist nun wenn wir betrachten dass
die russische seite versucht hier weiter
zu eskalieren nämlich in diesem
konkreten fall nach dem ereignis archiv
mit der zerstörung des stromnetzes
beginnt was bedeutet dass auch hier
zeigen wir ein kurzes video von den
auswirkungen dieser angriffe unmittelbar
nach dem erfolg der ukrainischen seite
ph gibt
es ist wichtig zu verstehen dass die
ukraine weiter unterstützt werden muss
möchte sie den kampf gegen russland
fortführen das betrifft vor allem die
lieferung von waffensystemen die
ukrainische seite hat zwei motive die
sie nützt um unsere unterstützung
aufrecht zu halten
einerseits das relativ europa gegen die
russische aggression zu verteidigen und
andererseits für unsere werte einer
demokratischen ordnung einzustehen im
kampf gegen russland
auf der anderen seite haben wir russland
russland hat ebenfalls negative die es
mit masse für die eigene bevölkerung
einsetzt hier sind folgende negative
wichtig erstens es ist nichts der kampf
russlands gegen die ukraine nein es ist
der kampf des westens der usa der nato
und europas gegen die russische seite
und es ist eine situation wie im großen
vaterländischen krieg dem krieg den wie
groß väter und großeltern geführt haben
gegen den faschismus
ist es wichtig zu verstehen dass diese
kommission der gesellschaft der kitt ist
der es möglich macht diesen krieg
weiterzuführen ich möchte ihnen das auch
hier an einem beispiel zeigen wo man
sieht dass aufgrund von propaganda
maßnahmen die russische seite versucht
die motivation der bevölkerung weiter zu
steigern
[Musik]
die frage die sich daraus ergibt ist
trotz der erfolge auf dem schlachtfeld
die sich sehen lassen können einerseits
wenn man hier betrachtet den vormarsch
der klinischen seite vor allem im raum
charkiw und quasi im vergleich zu den
russischen langsam voranschreiten in
tonbach kann es sein dass die
entscheidung nicht auf dem schlachtfeld
sondern an der heimatfront nämlich wenn
es um die unterstützung der ukraine bei
diesem krieg geht wir dürfen nicht
vergessen dass nicht die gesamte welt
die ukraine unterstützt sondern nur ein
teil nämlich die westliche
wertegemeinschaft
dürfen auch nicht vergessen dass der
westen möglicherweise unter druck kommt
in den nächsten wochen und monaten
aufgrund des umstandes dass suggeriert
wird dass die wegnahme der rohstoffe zu
einem massiven herausforderung in europa
führen
das bringt uns zu dem punkt dass wir
diesen konflikt wie ein kartenspiel
sehen müssen wo beide seiten um die
ukraine spielen ein staat hat mehrere
möglichkeiten macht zu projizieren er
kann diplomatie anwenden er braucht ein
lagebild er kann das militär einsetzen
und auch die ökonomie russland hat
dieses kartenspiel begonnen durch den
einsatz einer militärischen karte wir
haben das mit unserer ökonomischen karte
beantwortet durch die sogenannten
sanktionspaket nun hat russland
neuerlich seine karte ausgespielt und
zwar diesmal seine wirtschafts karte und
mit dieser wirtschafts karte versucht
russland uns in die knie zu zwingen die
entscheidende frage ist wer den längeren
atem und dabei haben wird
denn die wirtschaftliche herausforderung
ist nun also eine gewaltige und man
erkennt dass aufgrund von
demonstrationen in europa bereits fertig
sie durch die gesellschaft gehen umso
wichtiger ist es hier zusammen zu stehen
und zusammen zu halten und sich nichts
diesen angriffen informationsraum
auszusetzen
wir haben auch gesehen dass die
lieferung der westlichen waffen der
ukraine die möglichkeit gegeben hat den
konflikt neuerlich in eine richtung zu
verändern und auch hier sehen wir dass
die forderung der ukrainischen seite
nach wie vor jene ist nach schweren
waffen
wir müssen daher leider feststellen dass
dieser konflikt noch nicht zu ende ist
im gegenteil der konflikt wird
weitergeführt bis in unsere wohnzimmer
wir haben eine auseinandersetzung
einerseits auf dem gefechtsfeld aber
andererseits auch um die frage ob die
ukraine weiter unterstützt werden soll
oder nicht wenn die ukraine aus dem vest
nicht weiter unterstützt wird kann sich
diesen krieg vermutlich nicht weiter
fortführen auf der anderen seite
versucht russland genau hier anzusetzen
und einen keil in die europäischen
gesellschaften zu treiben um zu
erreichen dass diese unterstützung
eingestellt wird
an dieser stelle sage ich danke fürs
zuhören und bis zum nächsten mal
am ende noch ein kleiner nachtrag ich
möchte mich bei all meinen fans bedanken
die mich mit zuschriften entdecken unter
anderem auch jene die vermuten dass ich
einen russischen spion wäre hier wäre
interessant mich zuzuordnen welcher
dieser von mir genannten organisationen
ich an gehörig bin
ich möchte mich auch bei den absendern
der cea über 80 spam-e-mails bedanken
die jede woche von jungen damen gekommen
die mit mir kontakt aufnehmen wollen
leider muss ich ihnen mitteilen dass ich
hier nicht vorhabe diesen zu antworten
damit sage ich danke und bis zum
nächsten mal